great to have you on the program you're
going to be the first of the three
candidates that we are going to talk to
so what's the pitch
well very simply I want to do the job
because Scotland needs its independence
now more than ever before given this
totally cost of living crisis that is
causing so much misery and I believe I'm
the person that can lead Scotland to its
independence I have the experience over
a decade in government I can unify both
our party and our movement reach across
the Divide bring more people to support
the cause of Independence and also I
believe I am the person who will bring
policies forward that will ease that
cost of living crisis and help to grow
our economy both go hand in hand
so you you say there that you can bring
more people to your side or Independence
which of course is part of the jigsaw
but the other part is how you actually
get the second referendum in the first
place because the courts of rules you
can't have one without westminster's
permission so what would your plan be
have a referendum anyway or use the next
election as a de facto referendum
well look two things to say first of all
our opponents are desperate for us to be
stuck in some kind of Quagmire of
process I want to be talking about
policy it's very very simple actually
yeah but the process is important if
you're not allowed a referendum yes I
will come I will I will absolutely come
to the process don't worry but if we
build a sustained majority for
Independence not where some polls put us
at 51 some at 49 but a sustained
majority for Independence then those
political obstacles will disappear
Independence will become a political
inevitability so what I've said
yesterday is I will restart re-energize
and grow the yes movement and campaign
from the bottom up to get out there to
tell people and persuade them why we
desperately need our independence in
terms of process you're right I've said
quite publicly I'm not wedded to using
the next general election as a de facto
referendum I want to have a really
honest engaging discussion with our
membership not a one-off special
conference but a series of discussions
to to determine what the path forward as
being no doubt if I am leader of the SNP
every single election including the
general election will be about the issue
of Independence now we're going to play
my interview with Bernie Sanders after
our conversation I just want to read you
what he said on Scottish independence he
said I very much appreciate what the
people of Scotland have done and what
they're fighting for my initial thought
is they want to go their own way they
should be allowed to you could try and
get him on the campaign
but actually Bernie gets it it should be
for the people of Scotland to decide
that's not just actually Bernie Sanders
view if you wanted to come a little bit
closer to home I've heard Mark Drakeford
who is a labor Welsh politician who
doesn't believe in Independence but I
said very unequivocally that it should
be up to the people to decide we have a
mandate and you talk about what is the
preferred route actually the preferred
route would be that Westminster doesn't
deny democracy to Scotland gets round
the table gives the section 30 order so
we can hold that legal referendum just
as we did in 2014 we had two governments
diametrically opposed in the issue
coming together respecting the Mandate
we had and allowing a referendum to take
place they're not doing that they're
denying democracy and that's why I'm
going to ensure that we build the
popular support okay um is it I won't be
doing my job properly to say that some
people would question that Mandate of
course you uh did win the last election
in Scotland but there hasn't been that
sustained majority impulse supporting
Independence I'm quite Keen to talk
about honestly don't know I honestly
don't know how you could I honestly
don't know how you could question them
Andy we have stood time and time and
time again on a manifestation if we were
to win the election then we would we we
would have the Mandate for reference
with one election after election after
election including of course post brexit
where we said Scotland was dragged out
of Europe against its will okay as I
said as I said I wouldn't be doing my
job properly if I didn't put the
all-time perspective across there's
other things I'm Keen to talk to you
about in the interview as well now
same-sex marriage has of course been a
big part of this leadership race with
the views of your rival candidate Kate
Forbes coming under scrutiny now back in
2014 you abstained on the final vote on
Scotland's equal marriage legislation
how would you have voted
no that's not actually true so I voted
at stage one for the bill uh why it
wasn't there at stage three is well
known and it was well known at the time
I had a meeting an avoidable meeting to
try to get a Scottish citizen who was in
Pakistan on blasphemy who had been
attacked on death row tried to get him
back to Scotland there was a series of
meetings that were taking place between
myself and the Pakistani government to
get this individual back home one of
those meetings was during the stage
three ball but let me be unequivocal
about it if I was there I would have
voted for it that was well known at the
time the fact that this is now being
dragged up nine years later in the midst
of an election contest by some people
who are supporting other candidates I
think as it probably tells you the
motivation behind it anybody can look at
my track record on equality and they can
see where I stand on a number of these
issues yeah you you say don't you that
you feel that's been dragged up the
former Minister Alex Neal says that you
were given cover to skip the boat and
the meeting that you talk about could
have been arranged another time just to
be Crystal clear on this do you think
that gay sex is a sin
oh look I've answered this question time
and time and time and time again no
matter how many times Sophie you asked
the question I believe in equal marriage
I believe that people's marriage if they
are gay and they are married that their
marriage is no less there's no more
inferior is worth less than my marriage
as a heterosexual individual so no I I
don't subscribe to that view I think
it's fine by the way I should say for
people to have
um their own personal faith I don't
think that we should bar anybody from
office for having their personal faith
in fact I look I I'm Muslim I I practice
my faith I'll be fasting in Ramadan in a
few weeks time for example the
difference I have is that I don't use my
faith as the basis for legislating I
don't think that's what people want
their legislators to do they want their
legislators to do what is in the best
interests of the country and and I will
continue that Progressive agenda that
Nicholas sturgeon has started and it has
built over the over the last eight years
under her first Minister under her
leadership as first Minister I'll
continue to do that and that will help
to grow support for Independence
you say there that you don't allow your
personal faith to impact legislation and
you stay very clearly there that you
think that equal marriage is something
that's important and something that you
fully back the question was do you
believe that gay sex is a sin
no if I could just be clear about that
that's not it's not I just I've been
asked a question about 25 times and I've
answered it the same way 25 times so I I
can't change what's in certain faiths I
can't change what's in scripture while I
can tell you is the approach that I will
take which is that I will not allow
personal faith to be the basis of
legislation okay one more kind of
culture question if you like and then
we're going to get on to your email on
health
um another question that I'm sure you
feel that has been asked 25 times in the
leadership race but I'm going to ask it
again it is Isla Bryson the transgender
prisoner convicted of rape is she a man
or a woman
well I think Eileen Bryson is that it if
I'm honest I think they're a dangerous
individual deceptive individual I don't
think they're a true trans women I think
they're trying to play the system for
personal Advantage now what I can't do
Sophie is I can't change law the law
which has been the law for many many
years allows I love Bryson to
self-identify as a as a woman if they
wish I think they're at it I don't think
they're a genuine trans women so I
wouldn't describe them in that way what
I would say is we need to be really
careful in this discussion because what
we can't do is roll back the rights for
those trans women the 99.9 who don't
commit any crime who live their lives
like you and I do not interfering in
anybody else's rights what we can't do
is regress and and and and decide to
curtail people's rights because of one
despicable individual so no I don't
believe Isla Bryson is truly and
genuinely a trans woman
Dominic Robb was on the program this
morning talking about his move to say
that if you are a trans woman convicted
of a sexual crime or a violent crime you
can't be housed in a woman's prison do
you would you like that to apply to
Scotland as well do you back that
oh yes it's got the Scottish prison
service recently updated their policy
and by the way they've been dealing with
these issues really well really complex
issues actually for many many years I
remember they were doing that in my team
when I was just a secretary but they've
changed and updated their policy that
any individual any man that has a
history of violence against women they
shouldn't be in the female prison estate
even during that kind of risk assessment
period I think that's probably where
some of the challenge existed with the
Isla Bryson case as you mentioned the
individuals never
able to cause any harm to the female
inmate inmates at court and Veil but
they probably shouldn't have been housed
there well the assessment was taking
place now I just want to talk a bit
about your record as health secretary a
e waiting times have gone up a quarter
of patients now waiting over 62 days for
cancer treatment you wanted to recruit
800 more GPS by 2027 but in the last
five years you've only managed 113. now
power-based survey for the Sunday Times
today found when asked write people's
performance as Government ministers Kate
Forbes had an approval rating of plus 14
Reagan got three and you've got minus
16.
that's not great is it well what what
I'd say is that any health secretary in
the midst of a global pandemic is going
to face the challenges that we're facing
up here in Scotland in fact those long
ways are replicated and whether it's
conservative LED England or whale labor
run Wales so those are common problems
faced right across the UK in fact in
Health Services right across the world
because the global pandemic has been the
biggest shock our NHS has faced in the
74 year existence but what's different
up here in Scotland well what's
different is the fact that the situation
hasn't been made far worse by nurses and
ambulance drivers going on strike we
have avoided strike action up here in
Scotland not by chance not by Good
Fortune but because I've reached out
engage with our Trade union colleagues
brought them round the table they've
engaged in good faith we've managed to
compromise where necessary and I think
those are pretty good skills for any
future leader or indeed any future first
minister to have okay just finally
Scotland V France and Celtic V Rangers
both kick up at 3pm what are you going
to be watching
no I'm actually going to be speaking to
activists in Aberdeen so I'm going to
end up missing the game I'm afraid both
of them what a nightmare thank you very
much for being uh on the program today
much appreciated